The saga is ending, but will the story live
on forever?
On December 16, the ninth Star Wars film and
the final installment of the Skywalker saga
The Rise of Skywalker had its world premiere
in Los Angeles.
Critics took to social media following the
event to share their thoughts about the film.
We hesitate to say that there's a general
consensus about The Rise of Skywalker at this
point, since full reviews have yet to be posted
online and because critics are barred from
revealing too much in their early reactions.
What we can say, however, is that there have
been more positive reactions to the film than
negative ones, with a common thread in critics'
tweets being that The Rise of Skywalker is
a larger-than-life, better-than-expected conclusion
to the 40-plus-year-long Skywalker saga.
Fandango's Erik Davis held nothing back.
He tweeted:
"Epic.
All of it.
[The film] is a terrific finale that is just
stuffed with so much of everything.
Action, adventure — answers!! — humor,
heart, love, and grit.
I spent the entire second half with tears
in my eyes – a wonderful way to end the
Skywalker story."
Entertainment journalist Jenna Busch was moved
to tears during the premiere of The Rise of
Skywalker, as it checked every box and delivered
on every promise.
She tweeted:
"OH MY GOD!
I am absolutely blown away!
I've never been so satisfied by a film.
This is the end of an era and a franchise
that has defined my life and this did it justice
in a way I didn't imagine it could.
You WILL cry."
Shortly after seeing The Rise of Skywalker
on Monday evening, Slashfilm founder Peter
Sciretta tweeted:
"JJ Abrams nailed it.
He was able to bring a cohesive arc to this
trilogy that feels like a fitting end to the
saga as a whole.
I'm so emotionally drained.
Star Wars fans will be very happy."
It appears that one way The Rise of Skywalker
accomplishes the lofty goal of ending the
Skywalker saga with a bold bang is through
fan service, which critics have conflicting
emotions about.
"I've got a bad feeling about this."
The official Twitter account for CinemaBlend
tweeted that The Rise of Skywalker is, quote,
"jammed with fan service" — but the kind
that will probably divide fans and spark heated
discussions about the Star Wars universe.
Film and television critic Yolanda Machado
shared that she wasn't entirely surprised
by the events of The Rise of Skywalker, and
felt that, quote, "too much fan service was
given."
However, those downsides didn't detract from
the overall greatness of what The Rise of
Skywalker does and accomplishes in her eyes.
Machado tweeted that the film is, quote, "everything
and nothing that you're expecting."
She went on to say:
"God I love this franchise and I'll miss the
Skywalker saga."
Award-winning journalist and film critic Scott
Mantz had similar feelings about the fan service
in The Rise of Skywalker: there's a lot of
it, but he really enjoyed the film as a whole.
He made no mention of what the result of packing
so much fan service into the film might be,
though, instead keeping his reaction contained
to his own excited thoughts.
He tweeted:
"Really awesome!
The best of the new trilogy!
Really fun, lots of humor, a big heart!
So many surprises!
It's everything #StarWars fans are hoping
for, and more!
A very satisfying conclusion!
A lot of fan service, but I loved it!"
You know the old saying: too much of a good
thing is a bad thing.
For some critics, this adage applies to The
Rise of Skywalker.
Mashable's Chris Taylor kept his feelings
about The Rise of Skywalker short and simple,
unlike what he felt the movie was.
He wrote:
"#TheRiseofSkywalker is a lot.
It's like 9 movies of plot in one.
Going to take me about 9 days to process."
Angie J. Han, also of Mashable, echoed Taylor's
sentiments in tweeting that The Rise of Skywalker
is "a lot."
She expanded, quote, "Tons to love here, no
shortage of crowd pleasing moments and twists
and cameos, but also quite a bit to [think
about]."
Han also hinted at an emotionally fulfilling
send-off for Carrie Fisher's Leia Organa,
and some heart-warming moments with new characters
Jannah and D-0, a little droid pal who looks
like he has a megaphone for a head.
Collider editor-in-chief Steven Weintraub
was particularly cryptic in his reaction to
The Rise of Skywalker, but what he did offer
following the premiere of the film suggests
that he may not have enjoyed it.
On Monday night, he tweeted:
"I might be in the minority on #TheRiseofSkywalker.
I have a lot to say but will wait till after
it has opened."
"I have a bad feeling about this."
OK, OK, you guys… we get it!
It goes without saying that these are but
a selection of the many first reactions to
The Rise of Skywalker that critics were able
to put out on social media without getting
into hot water with the legal departments
at Disney and Lucasfilm.
Far more in-depth reviews of the film will
be available to read once the companies lift
the review embargo for The Rise of Skywalker
on Wednesday, December 18 at 12:01am ET — a
full day before Thursday-night previews begin
on December 19.
As the world witnessed in 2017 with The Last
Jedi, everyone is going to have their own
unique opinion about The Rise of Skywalker,
and there could be a big divide between critics
and fans once the flick officially launches
in theaters.
While absorbing other people's reactions to
a movie is generally a harmless, hype-boosting
activity in the lead-up to the premiere, it's
important to remember that just because millions
of people love the same property you do, it
doesn't mean you'll see eye to eye with them.
That said, it's best to head into your Rise
of Skywalker screenings this week with an
open mind that's prepared for anything and
everything to happen.
You may love it, or you may hate it, but the
only way to find out is to see The Rise of
Skywalker yourself on Thursday, December 19.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.